let's look at the airline industry why
these guys got hit hard by the pandemic
most people don't realize the airline
industry's margins are only three point
two six percent I know it's smaller we
may not be able to see it their cost and
expense is ninety six point seven four
percent they barely make any money let
me speak to what this means here's what
this means
you know how companies who sell software
and you for instance do 20 million a
year but the 20 million year you do 70%
of profits you're really doing what 14
million year versus another company that
does 200 million a year but their
profits is only five percent they're
making only ten million a year so so the
company that's doing 20 million profits
more than a company doing 200 million
because of what they're profiting now
what their revenues are right 20 million
revenue sixty seventy percent profits
twelve million two hundred million
revenue five percent profits is ten
million
it's not about revenue it's about
profits and the airline industry's
profit net margin is three point two six
percent this is why you know the airline
industry's has historically been the
sexy industry let me go create my own
airline and most people don't realize
there's 27,000 commercial jet aircrafts
valued at six hundred and ninety six
billion dollars of which of which these
Airlines thirteen thousand three hundred
commercial jets valued at 331 billion
dollars are owned by operating the
lessers meaning they're being leased
they're not owned so these airlines like
Virgin Airlines you think it all must be
like a twenty billion dollar company it
only sold for two point six billion
dollars two point six billion dollars
Alaska Air Group bought it for two point
that's a virgin you know virgin the nice
sexy airline that Richard Branson starts
and you know you've been on it before
the pink lights and the music that they
play it's not that big of an industry
and they got exposed the airline
industry is taking a very big hit
because people are starting to realize
you cannot go into an industry just to
be able to say hey I'm gonna start my
own airline that David airline's why
because it's such bragging rights you
can go do it
business it's not a big deal but it's
not as sexy as profitable as people
think it is people are starting to pay
attention to numbers they didn't pay
attention to before
[Music]